uh so I'm sorry I'm trying trying to
start a tradition which is having a
picture of the audience up on Twitter so
I'm going to shoot your pictures and
then they're going to go up on Twitter
and so we're just going to do that half
the room because this room is wide
enough that I can't get the entire thing
but anyway I just just announced the
talk on Twitter so hopefully people will
tune in for the a live stream I'm hang
on actually need to post this now yeah
hopefully it's done and now I need to
turn turn on my phone on airplane mode
for this gentleman over here which
you're going to do okay all right so
thank you for the introduction and I
want to say thank you again to the
organizers of this group it's been a
fantastic workshop this is the last day
I'm going to try and keep things a
little bit light we're gonna have a
light introduction there'll be some meet
at the end but we're going to have a
little bit bit of fun with this talk um
so there's some missing stuff in my
title two words some gaps and obvious
problems with it anyway we're going to
look at sort of what these are from a
large-scale matrix computations
perspective for network problems so this
talk is going to involve a lot of very
old references so this is the first
paper that someone pointed me to that
takes a network and looks at it as a
matrix so this is a study of children
playing in a preschool from 1928 this is
by someone in hell and bought written
something called genetic psychology
manuscripts I this journal no longer
exists but here is the picture that they
had in there so if you remember back on
day one we saw lots of people drawing
adjacency matrices are sorry networks as
adjacency matrices this may be the first
adjacency matrix ever plotted if someone
knows references that go before this and
I'd love to hear or hear hear hear about
them there's actually some interesting
stuff here they they have five different
attributes for each of the links here
which is how the kids were playing with
each other and how many times they play
to play eight each other so if you just
blink and say we're going to put an edge
where there was any interaction at all
you get this really dense network
and throughout the rest of the talk
we're going to take networks and look at
them as matrices so we're just going to
buy buy into this methodology okay so
whenever you have the matrix and there
was this movie a whole may a whole bunch
of years ago called the matrix that
makes for good jokes and talks so here
now you have a choice so if you remember
the movie there was a choice you could
either learn how the world really works
or you could stay sort of blissfully
ignorant so here we're going to have a
red pill and a blue pill the red pill is
you're going to accept what or sorry at
least have the temporarily accept what
might be called The Matrix thesis which
is that everything that's computable on
a computer might be best explained as a
matrix problem the the blue pill is of
course the case where you can believe
whatever you want to believe and and the
rest of the thought you'll you'll wake
up in it and you won't remember any of
this stuff so we're going to see how far
the rabbit hole goes with with looking
at these things as matrices okay then
when your grad student you also spend
lots of time making pictures so this is
my advisor Jean Gallup who sadly passed
away about six years ago but cha cha
charge Charlie van loan is very much
alive these two guys wrote what's what's
commonly called the Bible on matrix
computations it's now in volume four but
if you're interested in matrix
computations you haven't seen them
formal yet I'm assuming if not like i'm
sooo most people here have seen most of
these things before but this is a great
great reference to start from after
you've read a couple of the other ones
this is a reference book it's not a
teaching book so it's great once you
sort of know things i need to look up
esoteric deep details about how to
implement the methods or how how how how
how they vary okay so I normally I would
have said matrix computations in a
nutshell but here we're going to do red
pill instead because this is the red
pill sis
scenario so the the the sort of standard
litany matrix computations is that once
you state a problem as a matrix problem
you want to take the structure of that
problem and use it to solve your problem
better okay so what does better mean
well it depends on the application so
better might be more accurately so I
have some friends working on solving
problems in quadruple precision
arithmetic because they get the wrong
answer if they solve it in double
precision arithmetic I have other
friends working on solving things faster
because they need things just to go
faster they're running on the
supercomputer and they and and it would
take them a year to solve their problem
right now and they want to solve it in a
week so a year to a week is a big
improvement in speed but the idea
throughout all of the field is to use
the structure of a particular matrix
problem in order to make things better
so what we're going to do is see how
that plays out in terms of a particular
graph algorithm alright so in general
this is my research area so what what
what what I do as a person is if you
come to me with a problem the first
thing I'm going to do is stay as a
matrix problem so that's that's that's
sort of me taking the red pill
wholeheartedly but what we're going to
see today is a whole bunch of
application of this to network analysis
and then one other application at the
end on network alignment that'll really
allude to is it's an interesting area of
open problems where we really do need
help as far as pushing things things a
further alright so what's what are we
going to see in this talk we're going to
see one canonical problem from this
perspective of taking a problem looking
at as a matrix and this is solving a
linear system of equations that comes
from a network so here a is going to be
our adjacency matrix D is going to be
our art degree matrix so what we're
doing here is we're taking our jason c
matrix transposing it and and hitting it
with our inverse degrees and then we're
solving a fixed point of this equation
so they're markers somewhere I mean I'm
just going to write this up on the board
so
as this if I don't remember if I put
this on all of the other slides but the
vast majority of this talk is going to
be about solving this equation or if you
write it as more of the standard fixed
point equation this is just alpha a
transpose D inverse X plus F alright so
those of you who know about these things
will recognize this as the page rank
equation so she's taught talked talked
talked about this last time this is also
personalized page rank depending on what
you choose F to be it's also something
called semi-supervised learning on
graphs so in art Owens talk he alluded
to some of these results but you can
take many of the equations that people
use for semi-supervised learning on
graphs where you have a label at some of
the nodes and you want to interpolate it
to the rest of the nodes as solving an
equation of this form as well people use
this equation to do all sorts of
different things so one of them is
protein function prediction you know
some functions of proteins and you want
to see what the function of other
proteins in your network might be people
use those to do gene Association
experiments you would have a noisy
sample from an experiment and what you
want to do is figure out what your your
your measured data on genes might might
have missed I don't have time to talk
about this but it's actually used for
for that network alignment problems and
there was a really curious application
of this to studying food webs what they
wanted to know was what was the most
important species in a network or in a
food network and what they did was they
would compute the solution of this
equation remove a species from the
network and see how much damage that
would do to to your solution of that
vector so solving this equation comes up
all over the place and sort of applied
network science so so it's used all over
the point what are these two alpha and F
parameters so f is generally given we're
going to look at one very special case
with F
and alpha you can either interpret as
the teleportation parameter and PageRank
so the way I'm staying at here is where
alpha is equal to one is the hard case
and alpha is equal to zero is the
trivial case or you can interpret it as
a regularization parameter or it's some
type of error in your network there's
there's a lot of different ways of
thinking about that that number so we've
already seen this a couple times so
vahab ha talked about this on Monday
Carl talked about this on Monday both of
them were using this to do clustering
analysis so they were finding good
communities or clusters of your network
by solving these equations and looking
at their solutions and they of course
want to solve Saul solve them fast art
use this and his talk on prediction
yesterday Jen had one slide on it in a
slightly different form but she did have
an equation that looked looked like like
this with a couple of twists on there
and then I know Sebastiano vigna has
looked this a lot in other contexts
including centrality and ranking
although he gave a talk on something
different here so again we've seen a lot
of these these equations over the course
of the week let's just sort of be
entirely concrete here and look at one
example of this so here's a very small
network the system of equations we solve
is an identity matrix here minus now
what happens when we do do this
particular trance transformation is the
out links of a particular node go into a
column of our matrix so here node one
actually links to everyone in the graph
and so we get a nonzero entry and every
in and every row in that column now it
turns out that this matrix D here is the
inverse of your degrees so the node one
here has has a degree six so we take all
of those entries and divide them by six
and so all we're doing with this
operation is cooking up a particular
stochastic matrix for a graph so this is
a column stochastic matrix if you're a
probabilistic probably about to shoot me
because you're used to thinking of roast
elastic mate matrices from a matrix
analista things are column stochastic
this equation works fine if you long
you have a substitute matrix so as long
as the sum of each column is bounded
above by one and it's a non-negative
matrix so this this handles all sorts of
different graphs and all sorts of
problems you can run into you can pretty
much just State this equation on any
graph you want and it always has a
unique solution which is because this is
actually a non non singular linear
system ok so here's an example of what a
solution of this looks like on a
slightly bigger graph so this is
Newman's net science graph this is one
that's slightly bigger and easy enough
to plot so this is 400 vertices I I
think of these things in terms of number
of non zeros in your matrix this is
twice the edge count if you like
thinking of undirected edges but the two
were largely equivalent now what I've
done is I just solved this where I set F
to have one single entry so f was equal
to zero everywhere except one note and
it was one so this is the personalized
page rank case we'll discuss in most of
the rest of the talk so f was just one
there and you can see what this does is
it sort of gives you larger nodes or
more color on nodes that are close by so
if she's talked talked about this in
terms of a distance measure there there
are some nice relationships between this
and sort of approximate distance
measures and graphs but what we're doing
here is just sort of illustrating what
you see with these and this is actually
the case we're going to look at for the
rest of the talk so we're going to look
at just computing the PageRank vector
the personalized PageRank vector for a
single node which means we're just
looking at a single column of the
inverse of this matrix
these solutions have very special
properties they're localized so what do
I mean by that suppose I take this and
run it on an even bigger graph so this
is a six sorry 800,000 node 6 million
edge crawl a flicker I did a couple
years years ago if I just compute the
solution of this in matlab and then run
plot on it what happens is the solution
looks like this so I'm showing you the
magnitude of the solution at every node
in this 800,000 node graph so if you
look at this you say well at 0 on most
of it the graph right no it's it looks
like it's 0 the way I'm plotting it here
except for these I think there's
actually 12 little spikes here so this
is what I mean by a localized solution
this thing looks like it only has a few
significant entries in it now it turns
out that that not entirely true what i'm
doing here is i'm showing you the error
in your your your computed solution with
que non zero so so i'm looking at the
solution with the K largest entries in
this and I'm saying how much of the
total solution does that explain and so
what you can see here is you get an
initial DK and then sort of a long long
long long long long tail here so this
ends up being about 12 here I think
there's 14 so there's 14 really large
entries here and then everything else is
sort of about the same order of
magnitude so these are what are called
localized solutions all of these entries
are mathematically nonzero so it's not
like there's rounding errors or anything
they're all really not zero so these
these are not sparse all right what's
the complexity of this well if you
stayed as a linear system this is
trivial it's 0 of n cubed of course we
can do better than that if you state
this as a sparse linear system in an
undirected graph it turns out you can
open up your latest stock and Fox
proceedings and
look at the latest result on solving sdv
systems on graphs so I can never
remember what this is but they keep
beating away at constants that look like
and here's a number of edges and so this
is some some some some some function
there now of course you don't need any
of this you can just look at what's
called the not knowing and series of
this particular linear system and get an
O of M or where m is the number of edges
algorithm but can we do better so I said
that the answers were localized can we
do do any better I said this was a talk
about old algorithms so here's a paper
from 1950s on solving linear systems
using monte car carlo methods so this
paper actually was never published it
was originally come up so it it was
originally an idea that came up by von
Neumann & Lomb and what they did is they
said if you construct a particular
random walk in any matrix you can solve
ax is equal to B by simulating this
random walk and so they go on to a
scribe and about a page so this is
effectively a Monte Carlo it it's a
generalization or it's a it's a more
general way of solving any system of
linear equations modulo some small
details with a monte car car car low
approach supposedly this was used in the
Manhattan Project to actually solve some
of the physics equations that they
needed to I use their all right so she's
told toll that's a little bit about
these but these have a long history of
being used for doing pagerank
computation and as that she said you get
really good complexity results for these
so these run in some linear time in the
size of your network so if you want to
solve a pagerank system you just need to
do approximately 0 of log of the number
of vertices work in order to solve one
of those pagerank systems using a Monte
Carlo method that's fast all right I
don't know if I'm going to have time to
go through this so we'll see how much I
do how much I get through there's
another really old class of methods to
solve ax is equal to B so this is a
linear system so a here on this single
slot
not the adjacency matrix of a network
it's a general linear system I'm just
describing it this way so if you open up
gollub and van loan you might be able to
figure out what this has to do with what
they talk about is gauss seidel there
how do you run gauss seidel or what's
called gauss South Pole explain the
difference in a second well all you do
at every step of this method is you take
your current solution or an
approximation of the solution X K and
you change a single entry in it J so all
you do is alter one single nonzero entry
sorry one single entry in your solution
vector and the way you pick it sorry the
way you change that single entry is you
make sure that the J equation in your
set of linear equations is satisfied so
what you do is you set the residual 20
so these are often called relaxation
methods because what you do is you relax
the J's term and then make sure your
equation satisfies that so you you relax
one single constraint solve it these are
also called coordinate descent methods
and if if your matrix has some
particular properties so how do you
choose these things well in Gauss Seidel
you just cyclically run through all the
coordinates of your matrix so if you
look at Gao side on the book they say
we're just going to run for each row of
our matrix from one to 2i N and just
repeat that there's another rule called
Gauss southwell where what you do is you
look at this equation that has the
highest violation of this so you look at
what's called the residual vector and
pick the element of the residual vector
that's the worst all right so now what
happens is we have a generic method what
we want to do is apply it to page rank
do I have enough time to go through this
yes good okay so there's two ways you
can apply this to page page rank and
this is something I'm not sure and
enough people know but so so so I'm
going to it at least explain it to this
this crowd and also record it for my
students so when they have to learn it
in the future I have a nice side
recording of it
what happens when you look at this set
of equations here and look at the j
throw of it well when you have this on a
matrix that just means you're looking at
a particular node J so here J is going
to represent the blue node in our graph
and what we want to do is figure out how
we're going to change that coordinate of
the PageRank vector well so what we do
is for this simple equation we just
write out what the PageRank solution
looks like so here i've got x here here
i'm going to write this equation out and
look at the j coco co ordinate and then
just alter that one now this identity
matrix on the j coordinate means that
this term is going to stand by itself
and all of the neighbors are going to be
in the old solution so we're just going
to change one single number here and how
are you going to change it you're going
to solve this such that you'll solve
this equation for this term which means
i just take this bunch of numbers and
add them to out the right-hand side so
in general what this looks like is you
solve these equations at every at at
every row for this term here in terms of
a graph what that means is you look at
all of your in links and you just say
how much of my in links are how much are
my in links telling me to update my page
page rank value and I just havin to take
that update so this is what I call page
rank pull because what you're doing is
you're looking at what you're in links
are telling you to I do and you're
pulling that information into yourself
this is actually a bit annoying because
you need access to the in links of a
node and if you're a guy like Justin
Bieber you have about 30 million of
these guys and it might be very
expensive to update your in links
there's another version this called
PageRank push which is where you invert
this and so what you do is we're going
to look at the same equation now but
we're where you have access to your in
links instead okay so you need one extra
bit of information to to to make this
algorithm work which is you need your
residual vector so are here is measuring
how much I violate my equations at
every node so in the PageRank push
algorithm what you're going to do is
just take your JS coordinate and add
your residual so there should be a k
here but you're just going to add
however much you violate that particular
equation why does this work well it
turns out if you look at this update and
the Jethro of this update here they give
you exactly the same thing because the X
here and the X here end up cancelling
out so these two got it so those those
those two end up canceling then what you
have to do is update RK updating RK
involves looking at how much you've
changed well I've now satisfied the jace
equation exactly and so what I'm going
to do is tell all of my neighbors how
much they need to change their residuals
by in order to account for the fact that
I've updated my soul solution so these
two procedures are doing exactly the
same matrix iteration all you're doing
is changing how you access the graph so
if you have that easy access to in links
you can run the algorithm on the left or
the left if you don't have easy access
to in links you can run the algorithm on
the right this is approximately this
many lines of Python code to have a real
implementation of this the slides will
be up online soon so I'm not going to
talk about this this has been used in a
whole lot of different application so it
was I believe first used for page rank
in this era su at all paper in 2002 this
is exactly what Anderson at all using
their push algorithm so what's the
complexity of this result for computing
a pagerank vector well it ends up being
order of machine or sorry order of the
number of edges of your graph Anderson
it all has a better bound but what they
do is they bound a different type of
residuals when you interpolate it back
to 2i the actual graph you end up
getting order of edges again now here's
where I think there's an interesting gap
if I do a Monte Carlo method and look at
the accuracy I get after looking at this
many edges so here I'm varying how many
algar how many edges the graph touches
and
looking at the approximation accuracy
and the one norm of a pagerank problem
so if i run the Monte Carlo algorithm it
decays I I would consider that slowly if
you run a relaxation method which is
just this Gauss Seidel procedure it
decays even more slowly and then it gets
very fast so this is an algorithm that
sub linear in theory because you get
this shape for any size network this
algorithm is order at E except that if
you want accurate solutions you would
never use this algorithm because this
will take a very long time to get down
down out here whereas that one always
gets down there very quickly so I claim
that there are two gaps here so the
first is it be nice to have algorithms
that are good in theory that also have
this this sub behavior as well I also
kind of plans that there's another gap
here it would be awesome to have sort of
Don Monte Carlo style albums their
hybrid algorithms that give you good
results up here so I want to take this
curve shift it down there and then take
this curve and shift it down down out
there so I'm out of time I inadvertently
put in too much in the introduction so I
apologize about that I do want to say
you can do a little bit better so we
have a recent result where you use a if
you assume that there's as if law and
your degree distribution you can
actually get slightly better asymptotic
convergence results that look like d
times log D times this ends up being one
over epsilon to the sixth so don't don't
ever ask me to explain why that's sorry
it's 1 over epsilon to the 6 which means
it's a it's a practically useless bound
however if you're willing to accept that
that's a constant this gives you similar
asymptotic runtimes if you fix epsilon I
want to talk a little about trying
triangles and make a joke on seshes talk
but I'm out of time here so
unfortunately it anyway there's some
interesting ideas on using triangles and
including them so I guess I just like to
end on this small list of other opened
direction
that might be worth worth up pursuing